día de electoral en francia avanza la
jornada en el país galo en la que se
decide quién será el inquilino del
palacio del elíseo durante los próximos
cinco años los candidatos a la
presidencia ya depositaron sus fotos
según una estimación de ipsos la
abstención a corte de las 5 de la tarde
ahora parece es del 28 por ciento
se cumplen dos meses del inicio de la
invasión rusa a ucrania en medio del
recrudecimiento de la ofensiva militar
las tropas rusas avanzan por el este del
país mientras que el gobierno ucraniano
devolvió vivir selenski espera la visita
del secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken para pedir más ayuda
en mexico entre reclamos de justicia
familiares y amigos asistieron al
sepelio de the bank y escobar la más
reciente víctima de violencia de género
en este país la joven de 18 años fue
hallada muerta el pasado jueves en el
norteño estado de nuevo léon tras dos
semanas desaparecidas
bienvenidos a este nuevo resumen
informativo en francés 24 es un placer
acompañarlos los saluda daniela blandón
comenzamos en francia cuyos habitantes
se eligen este domingo a su próximo
presidente en la segunda vuelta
electoral a las 8 de la noche hora local
terminan de cerrar las mesas de votación
para los 48 7 millones de ciudadanos
convocados a los comicios los candidatos
al palacio del elíseo ya depositaron sus
votos mientras tanto la más reciente
estimación de ipsos sobre asteria para
france 24
franz televisión radio france radio
francia internacional entre otros
publicada a las cinco de la tarde -hora
local- en parís señala que la abstención
de la jornada alcanzaría el 28 por
ciento
los detalles nos los entregan nuestro
periodista en parís luís miguel cabrera
la abstención en la segunda vuelta de la
elección presidencial se acercará a
28% es una información que acabamos de
recibir una estimación de ipsos obra
seria para france24
ese 28% es superior en 26 puntos a la
tasa de abstención de la segunda vuelta
de 2017 que fue de
25,4 por ciento es un dato importante
porque dados los resultados de la
primera vuelta se espera una tasa récord
de abstención en sentido general la
jornada transcurre sin incidentes los
franceses votan en calma como aquí en el
distrito 20 de parís en el noreste de la
ciudad luz también votaron ambos
candidatos marín le pen y emanuel macaco
lo hicieron en el norte del país en el
departamento de paso de cal de una
región estratégica para ambos los
aspirantes a la presidencia regresan a
parís hoy mismo para esperar el
resultado un resultado preliminar que se
conocerá cerca de las 8 de la noche y
para lo cual la alcaldía parisina ha
preparado un dispositivo de seguridad
excepcional
y para conocer todos los detalles de
esta jornada electoral los invitamos a
conectarse con el especial que tenemos
24 con la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales francesas eso
a partir de las 12 del mediodía hora de
ciudad de méxico bogotá quito y lima
presentado por nuestra compañera maría
clara calle
y hoy hace dos meses inició la invasión
rusa a ucrania que dejaba según naciones
unidas un saldo de al menos dos mil
doscientos civiles muertos y unos cinco
millones de refugiados
el presidente de volodymyr selenski
espera este domingo la visita en kiev
del secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken así como del secretario de
defensa a lloyd austin un encuentro que
todavía no ha sido confirmado por la
casa blanca entretanto el comandante del
batallón ha soft que ha luchado contra
los separatistas rusos en el este de
ucrania condenó el recrudecimiento del
asedio ruso en medio de la celebración
de la pascua ortodoxa
queremos agradecer a aquellos que
conexiones ayudan a evacuar a los
civiles de mariupol y ayuda a nuestros
soldados que luchan contra el enemigo
scott yo hago un llamado a la comunidad
mundial para que haga todo lo posible
para ayudar a esos valientes guerreros a
napo próximo
a tener la oportunidad de contar sus
historias a sus familiares y recuerde en
el momento en el que estén enviando sus
tarjetas de pascua y disfrutando de la
tregua el enemigo está arrojando bombas
sobre las cabezas de niños inocentes en
varios crímenes cristerna murió desde su
hijo protium también está eta seguimos
hablando de la guerra porque previo a su
encuentro con altos funcionarios
estadounidenses
volodymyr selenski sostuvo una
conversación telefónica con su homólogo
turco recep tayyip erdogán justo antes
de que éste último haga lo propio con
vladimir putin según el gobierno de
ucrania en la llamada del mandatario
recalcó la necesidad de la evacuación
inmediata de civiles de la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol mayoritariamente
ocupada por rusia ya el comité
internacional de la cruz roja había
pedido este domingo que se habilite un
corredor humanitario en la zona incluida
la planta acerera de as hostal el
principal bastión ucraniano que todavía
queda en el puerto de mariupol
y una de las ciudades más asediadas es
esa en donde el más reciente ataque con
misiles dejó al menos 8 muertos y varios
heridos con motivo de la celebración de
la pascua ortodoxa el alcalde de la
ciudad portuaria condenó el avance de
las tropas rusas hacia el este y también
la muerte de civiles en medio de la
ocasión religiosa
respecto a ustedes saben que el agresor
ruso los ocupantes y asesinos están muy
orgullosos de sus armas creo que tienen
todas las posibilidades de saber
exactamente dónde atacar por eso digo
que estos ataques se hacen
intencionadamente en lugares
residenciales porque si le dices al
mundo entero sobre tus armas de alta
precisión que haces ataques de alta
precisión en la infraestructura militar
es falso y mentira que están haciendo
ataques precisos en zonas residenciales
donde la gente se preparaba para la
pascua que está más allá de la
comprensión
georg reunión vamos ahora a áfrica
porque en nigeria se estima que más de
100 personas murieron durante una
explosión de una refinería ilegal de
petróleo en la frontera entre los
estados de rivers e imos en el sureste
de la nación según las autoridades el
desempleo y la pobreza han hecho que la
refinación ilegal de crudo sea un
negocio atractivo pero con consecuencias
mortales en el mayor productor de
petróleo de áfrica en este tipo de
actividad el crudo se extrae de una red
de oleoductos propiedad de las
principales compañías petroleras y
después de ser refinada en peligrosos
tanques improvisados
en japón al menos 10 muertos y 16
desaparecidos reportan las autoridades
tras el naufragio de un crucero en la
región costera de hokkaido al noreste
del país la embarcación turística a casi
1 con 26 personas a bordo había perdido
el rastro el sábado después de reportar
que comenzó a llenarse de las aguas
gélidas de las costas de chile tocó una
península muy apetecida por turistas
silvestres y declarada patrimonio de la
humanidad por la unesco la operación de
rescate tuvo dificultades para los
socorristas por las bajas temperaturas
que alcanzaron a caer por debajo de los
cero grados
y cambiamos de región en mexico
despidieron a la joven de baní escobar
una estudiante de derecho que se
encontraba desaparecida desde el pasado
9 de abril y que luego de 13 días de
intensa búsqueda fue encontrada cerca
del lugar donde fue vista por última vez
la sociedad pide justicia no solamente
por este caso sino también por la
creciente violencia de género y el
número de mujeres víctimas de
feminicidio en el país
familiares y amigos despidieron a t banc
y escobar más de tres horas caminaron a
través del municipio de galeana en nuevo
león para darle el último adiós a la
joven mexicana de 18 años desaparecida
el 9 de abril el padre de de bani exige
justicia y rechazó que dejaran libre al
taxista que según vídeos de la fiscalía
la acosó sexualmente para luego dejarla
abandonada en horas de la noche en una
carretera de salinas
la persona
es
el caso y la acción de las autoridades
ha desatado el descontento social
as
el padre denuncia poca transparencia en
las investigaciones luego que el equipo
de búsqueda rastreará en cuatro
oportunidades la misma zona para
encontrar el cuerpo de la joven y que lo
hallaran en solo hasta el pasado juegos
pondremos todos los recursos en nuestras
manos para determinar los hechos que han
sucedido
si estos indican un delito serán
perseguidos con toda la fuerza de la ley
en nuevo léon cinco mujeres han sido
asesinadas y 26 han desaparecido en lo
que va de este año en el país según
datos oficiales en los últimos siete
años se han registrado cerca de cinco
mil 700 víctimas de feminicidio y
17.620 de homicidio doloso lo que indica
que en promedio 9 mujeres son asesinadas
y cada día en mexico
hasta aquí es informativo quédense con
nosotros para más información y también
sigan el especial a partir de las 12 del
día ahora bogotá quito lima y ciudad de
méjico sobre las elecciones
presidenciales en francia